[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
a boy duncan can i trust you something
yes always you know that i've been
having dreams
about a girl on a ruckus i don't know
what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
hey you put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house of tradies there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling the emperor
asks us to bring peace to arrakis house
atreides
accepts
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready you've never met
harkins before they're not human they're
brutal
the duke's son sees too much
this is why dude kill them all
god in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
dad what if i'm not the future of house
of tradies
a great man doesn't seek to lead he's
called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
all together please stand a chance
[Applause]
it's time
i'm having visions
the body of dr florence weaver was found
brutally murdered in her home this
morning
did you know her no but i saw her die
i'm saying that
i'm seeing murders as they're happening
hello
he says his name is gabriel
i think he's someone from my past
whatever happened to you before you
joined our family
hurt you in a way that i can't even
imagine
who are you talking to gabriel
is he your imaginary imaginary friend
[Music]
he's the devil
[Music]
whatever it was it's back
he killed again he's getting closer
he wants to talk to you
mom what do you know
[Applause]
who's coming for me
who are you gabriel
oh there they are ladies and gentlemen
the bride and groom to be emily and
marcus
what the hell is that you son of a [ __ ]
you said we were best friends
what are you two doing here
excuse me this is a private event oh
it's cool we know the bride and groom
we bet these two animals down in mexico
[Music]
why does the salt not taste salty oh
because it's cocaine what
i don't do drugs even on vacation
okay look we just got a this only
happened because you said see you later
i said it without meaning that like any
decent person would
and somehow he's charming my dad hope
you're comfortable and enforcing oh if
there's at least one girl involved
everywhere they go
[Music]
this weekend is all about you well i
like the sound of that
we do too good evening everyone what is
he doing
marcus and i cross paths in mexico get
to know each other
intimately this is the best wedding i've
ever been to
put that bottle on your head babe he's
not serious we've been drinking it
count it you hit the bottle this time
what
there is only one question that matters
do you swear on your life
[Music]
that what you say is true
[Music]
my father told me my life will be
blessed with good fortune
[Music]
i'm married
i was a good wife
and then was judged and shamed by my
country
[Applause]
i say before all of you
i spoke the truth
the most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
chocolatree entered our home
he attacked me the accusation is false
i am telling the truth the truth does
not matter
there is only the power of men
this should be settled quietly innocent
i request a duel to the death if you
lose
your wife will suffer dire consequences
one of us has lied let us let god decide
you do not believe me i am risking my
life for you
you are risking my life so you can save
your pride
penalty forbearing false witness
is that you are to be burned alive
i will not be silent
we'll meet again
don't know where don't know when
but i know we'll meet again
some sunny day hello i'm johnny
knoxville welcome to jackie
three two one
a lot of people ask what will jackass be
like once we're older
well it'll get more mature
the faster you pedal your bike the
faster the other guy's hand goes back
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything concussions aren't great
but as long as you have them before
you're 50 it's cool
and knoxville's 49 so we're good
can you feel my heart wow
today we're going to do a little
furniture shopping
i've been watching jackass since i was
12 years old
and guess what we're here
[Applause]
we have winners and we have steve a
bunch of nasa sciences right
what did you guys do to eric fail to
prepare
prepare to fail
you still got those million dollar teeth
that's for sure
gee didn't set myself up for failure on
this one
aaron please relax i'm trapped
and you're putting honey on me and
salmon
oh my god
oh my gosh
i am a public defender of the u.s
criminal justice system
[Music]
you have the power to waive a mandatory
minimum next docket
once you fall in it's almost impossible
to get out
tough week for your champ my client
pleads not guilty
get out with all due respect
but what if you can beat the system at
his own game
[Music]
so this guy asked me if i'd help him out
nobody's car got jacked
you let me know it's there
he offered me a hundred grand if i grab
a sample of the heroine stashed inside
that navigator
why risky i don't wanna live my life
looking at lost opportunities
let me post this hypo i mean you could
steal said monies
without detection i still wouldn't do it
why not
because it's wrong it's wrong it's wrong
it's
wrong think about what it can do
[Music]
one can break the law my friend and
still believe in justice
that isn't the first blip you've had
tonight is it someone's going to see 15
million dollars
all in one room think of the lives that
could change
i'm in
[Music]
this guy has me freaked you better not
be trying to get in the middle of
something that has nothing to do with
you
rehearsal this is our chance to carve
our names across the back ass of the
universe
legacy time
the cops i think they know
there's been a wrinkle a mexican cartel
they're here
this is what i do busting my ass trying
to level the playing field
i thought we said no guns it's tear gas
plus it looks badass as [ __ ]
[Music]
how is this possible
do you know what this place is
[Music]
your mother angela she's our patient
i've been out of touch with her for
a very long time thank god
her mind is very active in the
simulation stimulation
she went on a homicidal rampage
this is your chance to ask her why
mom carly you have to go
you have to go
guys please let me out can you hear me
guys are we doing no no no no no just
just wait
are you sure that you haven't been
having any hallucinations outside of the
simulation
[Applause]
demonic possession it can be real
i can't do this you want to end up like
your mother
the vatican has been funding the black
ops unit he's increased like
that it's soldiers it won't stop
coming for you
stop right there
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
well no one told me about her
the way she lied but it's too late
to say you're sorry how would i know
why should i care please don't bother
trying to find her
she's not there well let me tell you
about the way she looked
the way she acted the color of her
[Music]
why does nobody come in through the
front door dearest mother
and father we will not be attending this
evening's ritual mastication
what they're both growing up so fast
they wouldn't be caught
dead with their parents
wait a minute what i've got a dish
it's hideous it's monstrous
it's the old adam's camper
time for some family bonding what huh we
are going on a road trip
this is cruel even for you
this trip will bring the atoms closer
than ever before
let's make some memories
[Music]
[Music]
it's just us and the wonderful sound of
silence
[Music]
now that's great
[Music]
yes
good to see you my b whiskered cousin
i still don't understand the word that
guy say
was kitty he and it hit the catnip
pretty hard last night
[Music]
forest have always burned
and they always will it's a love nature
it's a crown fire we can't stop it
everything will be lost that simple
you're taking me along so that i'd fly
with you see a real fire and realize
it's no joke am i getting that right
pops
catch a burn and run off home that type
of thing
i can see that you're scared hello roma
and what if i send those planes out
there for nothing who's gonna answer for
that
i will if nobody else will
if these aren't your own people
then who are
we're getting the villagers evacuated
and ready to hit the road
the road's on fire
i'll be just fine
i promise
take her lower oh come on come on come
on
[Music]
on your knees
[Music]
hi uncle jack the old cabin looks good
country will be good for you this lake
it has a way of healing things thanks
for driving
okay bye bye
i'm over this jimmy read the room you
know the protocol
that's not how we talk that's not what
we do
hi hi
billy we haven't unintended clean up
your goddamn mess
don't you make me have to come out there
please i'm begging you please please
please you don't have to do this i
promise what are you waiting for billy
move on your knees now
i'm a cop what happened she assaulted me
they're lying
she murdered someone this guy's a cop
he's not gonna shoot another cop
billy get my gun run
we got a problem put her out of her
misery and then let's finish this
you here i can hear you in there
where's your friend
you can trust me what we need is
evidence i need my camera
everything that you need to know is on
there
there's no quitting now you understand
it's okay
bring me the girl jack and your knees
stay safe
i swear if you touch my knees
we're in this together it gets real
tricky when families involved doesn't it
jack
i know men like you you use people to
get what you want
but i'm that chick you shouldn't have
messed with
[Music]
you